très bien m
ça vous va très bien ses jardins jafar à
lorient mais oui sentimentalement lui il
un peu bon rebond s'est compliqué la
tâche compliquée et id
c'est bien ce que j'ai cru savoir
puisque je suis en train de mener une
petite enquête et à faire sur cette
personne est un sujet donné avec une
avec avec un acolyte voilà qui on est on
enquête a deux filles sasha n'ont pas
dit non officiels pas du tout oui oui
vous dites ce que vous voulez mais
sachez que nous sommes en enquête sur
vous on aura les premières conclusions
de l'enquêté milieu de semaine prochaine
20h40 on est en direct on sera en direct
encore demain extra la suite à d'autres
à fabas j'espère oui payer nos chers on
y va mais ces plongées parti alors je
suis revenu avec des images de série
aujourd'hui encore une fois je suis
passé sur si près de chez vous sur idf1
alors dans si près de chez vous c'est
une série qui est basé sur des faits
réels problème c'est que quand
l'intrigué pas ou fort heureusement les
acteurs acceptent de donner des vrais
secrets sur eux des trucs qu'on n'avait
pas forcément cramer au début quoi
j'adore jean a depuis toujours un
terrible secret et si ces derniers mois
il s'est montré si étrange c'est qu'il a
de plus en plus de mal à vivre avec ce
matin-là il a enfin décidé de rompre le
silence
je m'attendais à un truc de ouf
si gentil surtout son secret se voit
quoi temps-ci restée deux jours la grève
dans things la storyline en rendez vous
faire vous vous êtes très beau comme ça
comme ça je vais aller livrer comme ça
demain matin je crois par en camion on
dirait les montendrais en a pour tous je
suis restée sur si près de chez vous
alors je suis tombé sur les personnages
qui a absolument tenu à dédicacer son
quartier pendant un épisode
son personnage est mort au bout d'une
minute 13 du coup il a tenu à dédicacer
même après sa mort ça c'est assez
bizarre
près de narbonne
un homme de 50 ans est retrouvé
inconscient dans son bureau le délire
spécial casse des 10 11 7 8 11 3
j'aime bien mûrs comme sa position super
d'être graciés ouf
bon après ça je suis passé sur ma race
et une telenovelas portugaise qui
cartonne au portugal ça cartonne
s'agissait alors du côté da costa del
sol aussi ça du coup l'udc s'est on au
portugal on sait que sur on sait qu'au
portugal au niveau du code du travail
sont pas aussi rigoureux que nous ce
sera un peu plus en détente
comment est-ce que tu peux être aussi
ingrat au bout du compte qui est-ce qui
paye ton salaire à la fin du mois
personne ne va bien après ça je suis
passé sur daniela une autre télé novelas
mont-sainte-anne connaissent à la whey
vous adorez bajur non monsieur paul
chandler pas mouche cola et battant
daniela ce qui est bien c'est que quand
deux actrices sont en désaccord et bien
très vite trouver un accord on s'en fout
du scénario sa solution comme afin
pourquoi toi et tué sa mère allez aimer
n'est pas peut avaler aller chercher
l'eau allait une fois le chercher l'eau
et qui bâille année
toi bien ouais bon après ça j'ai regardé
le prime au contraire de vous j'ai
regardé le prime qui marche est le moins
bien hier soir c'est quoi c'était sur
ses stars et ça s'appelle le duan sous
haute surveillance
oh merde c'est notre groupe alors
c'était pas sur ses stars ses stars
j'adore me sers toi rigoler c'est la
seule et moi j'adore cette chaîne tu
vois maigri de minutes après tu vois
frères ya papa n'en sait guère
c'est pape en son nom du coup je crois
savoir pourquoi ça marche pas super bien
c'est parce que quand on suspecte doit
donner une explication c'est tellement
confus est tellement longue qu'on a le
temps de voir ces zones le pouce et sa
bande et on ne vous a pas arrêté en 2009
en 2009 c'est moi réfléchir
en 2009 vous dites faut que j'y
réfléchisse une seconde mais c'est moi
cogiter un instant où est-ce que c'était
déjà en 2009 dans 2009 je crois qu'on
attendait dans une seconde
il faut que je me concentre non sens
qu'est ce que je foutais déjà en 2009
on n'aura jamais la réponse a est
l'adage jamais donné un bon ça on n'aura
jamais la réponse qu est ce que ça vous
dit qu'on joue un petit jeu à lévis mais
c'est quoi la suite tu es parti
connaissez le concept je démarre une
séquence où l'art est en plein milieu et
je vous demande la marine
alors ça s'est passé ce matin sur ses
news pendant la météo je vous laisse
regarder le début de la séquence fois
l'équivalent d'un mois et demi de pluie
vraiment aucun épisode méditerranéen qui
s'est mis en place cette nuit alors
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer et
c'est quoi la suite petite heure la
présentatrice météo va connaître la peur
de sa vie
petit feu y aurait un anticyclone en
forme de pénis sur la carte petit roi
elle va positionner toulouse dans le pas
de calais normal ou petits 4 parce
qu'elle prouve à rentrer en plateau et
se peindre d'un de la présence d'un
voile nuageux sur paris
allez c'est parti sur toutes les régions
autour du golfe du lion j'ai travaillé
sur sa pratique les sourires on sent
petit deuxième ont tiré hier à limoges
était dans les chiffres et des lettres
alors vous laisse regarder le début jean
pierre janot là à la parole comme ndoye
elle tâte laurent vous c'est quoi la
suite petit à un candidat se pensant
moderne va faire un dab petit 2 bertrand
renard va nous parler de ces soirées
folles à nikon hausse de 6,3 à rien ne
va chanter ou achat alors de jul ou
petit 4 romejko backlash est violemment
bertron moi je mets un boeuf romejko va
claquer sa silhouette vous regarder
l'émission
ces parties où j'avais dû tout ça
jean pierre janot l'un à la parole comme
une voyelle 4 laurent romejko on met 3
mais je trouve et laurent romejko n'y
croit pas on va sur les micro trop de
bon comme vous le savez aujourd'hui
c'est halloween
du coup bah moi je voulais me déguiser
mais malheureusement j'ai déjà ribéry
kroos oui mais voilà du coup je suis
allé demander à des français dans la rue
j'en ai pris deux au hasard deux géants
installés deux cabines d'essayage leur
ai demandé de rentrer dedans
le plus vite possible d'enfiler le
costume qui était dans la cabine et de
ressortir le plus vite possible
le premier costume et gagner un cadeau
parce que je l'emmène des cadeaux de
temps en temps problème pendant que le
premier changé on sait tous ce bar en
courant et on l'a laissé dehors en
costume
alors appelez moi ton prénom qui
n'atteint 50 je t'appelle année comment
tu t'appelles stanley le voir rentrer
chacun dans une cabine ans philippe
coste une quête intérieure et ressortir
avec les costumes le premier qui sort
remportent les cadeaux 3 2
on y va en temps
binic et alors c'est moi c'était comment
vous êtes des boîtes art m
alors ça fait quoi petite fille dix ans
de boîte a rapporté mois sur fond rose
est franchement ça va super bien